ich tue mich immer schwer mit den
vergleichen insbesondere mit
inselstaaten australien japan taiwan
südkorea halbinsel ist ein unterschied
ob sie in der mitte eines kontinents
liegen wie wie deutschland mit offenen
grenzen kommt selbst von der
niederländischen grenze hunderttausend
millionenfachen austausch über die
grenze im alltag übrigens auch zur
aufrechterhaltung des gesundheitswesens
notwendig oder ob sie auf einer insel
jeden der per flugzeug rein kommt dann
eben tatsächlich auch im zweifel testen
und nachvollziehen können das ist eine
ganz ganz unterschiedliche ausgangslage
und wir müssen einen weg finden und
darum ringen wir ja auch jeden tag unter
der prämisse gesundheitsschutz sehr sehr
stark zu gewichten der gleichzeitig aber
für ein land in der mitte dieses
kontinents und in der mitte der
europäischen union und das war ja auch
thema gestern beim europäischen rat
idealerweise im gleichklang mit seinen
nachbarn und da wo es eine völlig andere
politik in einem nachbarland gäbe was
ich im moment nicht sehe
möglicherweise auch mit entsprechenden
maßnahmen an der grenze verbunden damit
umzugehen und deswegen sehe ich null als
dauerhafte ziel marke nicht das was in
einem land wie deutschland mit unserer
lage und situation funktionieren kann
das funktionieren kann und soll ist die
infektionszahlen möglichst weit runter
zu bringen möglichst niedrig wir hatten
ja schon mal drei pro 100000 500.000 an
incidents in deutschland wird es ist ja
nicht so dass wir das nicht schon mal
geschafft hätten miteinander und
tatsächlich in eine situation zu kommen
mit möglichst wenig infektionsgeschehen
und kontrolle über das
infektionsgeschehen aber die
ausgangslage ist eine so andere dass ich
das modell jedenfalls nicht für auf
deutschland übertragbar
herr schumacher aber er will ja ich
wollte ich habe es noch nicht ganz
verstanden ob sie das geschafft ist ja
dass dann auch meine antwort erstmal
meine position wieder
zunächst möchte ich noch eine ergänzung
zur pcr tests machen und das auch noch
mal klarstellen
deutschland hat eine reihe von sehr
guten ausgebildeten laboren wir haben
ein gutes qualitätsmanagement es gibt ja
entsprechende untersuchungen das wird
immer wieder akkreditiert manche sind
zertifiziert das heißt dieser gute hohe
qualitätsstandard das ist sicher nicht
in jedem land der welt so das müssen sie
auch einfach mal akzeptieren wir nutzen
pcr diagnostik auch zum beispiel hiv
oder hepatitis b und ganz klare
ergebnisse vorliegen wo wir wissen wie
gut die pc funktioniert wir wissen die
qualität der pc einzuschätzen die labore
wissen über funde zu bewerten zur
sequenzierung der entscheidende punkt
das möchte ich auch noch mal hier sagen
der entscheidende punkt ist dass wir so
viele menschen wie möglich schnell mit
pcr identifizieren und dann ist die
sequenzierung eine sequenzielle
nachgeordnete technologie die uns noch
mehr informationen gibt aber zunächst
mal ist das ganze wesen der pandemie
bekämpfung darin beruht ist dass wir
menschen identifizieren die dann
isoliert werden wenn sie positiv sind
damit sie nicht mehr ansteckend anderen
können und dann die kontaktperson in
quarantäne zu tun und dafür ist die pca
die basis und mit den antiken
schnelltest haben wir ein weiteres
werkzeug das nicht ganz so präzise ist
aber ebenfalls gut das heißt also da
fängt das an gerede über public health
maßnahmen und und das sind auch die
maßnahmen die dazu führen dass wir eben
die instanzen reduzieren und je näher
die inzidenz der 0 incidents kommt desto
besser ist das ja das heißt also glauben
sie uns dass für diese maßnahmen haben
diese public health maßnahmen und sie
sehen es gibt kein kein land der welt
das irgendwelche anderen maßnahmen hätte
sondern die frage ist wie können wir
kontakte beschränken
wie gelingt es uns noch in einem
bestimmten ausgleich mit anderen
eine menge von gesellschaftlichen
interessen die sie alle kennen und wir
müssen die inzidenz herunterbekommen das
gelingt nur durch einen sicheren test
die mit der pcr haben
dadurch dass wir gezielt testen dass
menschen ihre kontakte reduzieren und
dann kommen wir mit den instanzen runter
auf eine zahl dass wir das beherrschen
können und das entscheidende ziel ist
dann dass ausbrüche eben sofort erkannt
werden und eingedämmt werden ich sage es
noch mal dieselben maßnahmen mit denen
wir die gängigen virusvarianten es gibt
ja tausende von virusvarianten die
unterwegs sind es dass nur sind jetzt
drei wie erkannt wurden dass sie
wahrscheinlich biologisch besondere
auswirkung haben mit diesen maßnahmen
können wir eben auch diese varianten
beherrschen also das ist der
entscheidende punkt diese public health
maßnahmen damit können wir die zahlen
runter bringen und die leute wie sie
runter bringen desto besser für uns alle
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren